the key level super uber sahadevan
allegheny
rebellion Volodya muguruza character day
Kaden and Aliyah come a long drive from
a long since everybody
Shafiq I is eight months pregnant
she was forced to flee her home in
Myanmar during her escape she says she
was raped by soldiers when Shafiq
eventually made it to the roy india
refugee camp here in Cox's Bazar in
Bangladesh the 25 Road realized she was
pregnant the baby growing inside of her
a result of her rape this is chef Iike
story deceiver Garvey the most amazing
man who's had a serious layer buzzbundle
ariseth ah Tina why are we meeting in
laura herrera for neurology your night
Shafiq applied to her village in Rakhine
State along with her husband and their
two children they left in the dead of
night with nothing but the clothes on
their backs
dominar i additional mother-daughter met
dr. anything so my daughter located I
don't know did he like that horn I
cannot get me Laurie they don't kill
again re soldiers from the Myanmar
military first separated Shafiq her from
her husband and then they took away her
youngest child
Shafiq had lost a child and didn't know
if her husband was alive or dead she and
her four-year-old daughter were captives
of the Myanmar military chief Iike says
the soldiers would take the women up to
a mountain to rape them
no anybody you know culture - editor
moody GUI I had a phone chain Delahanty
Rara be hundred owner like that a new
kid on La Nina had even though she was
weak Shafiq I saw an opportunity and
took it was a Honda Honda and anybody
you know - I resumed as her dad I'm
gonna do today she done was dating long
enough while dealing how about for Dina
me she can't imagine italiana
Arash to the money whenever you are
working Tim no no need to visit us we
doing our homework
commandant samaram erotically tarrallton
are like oh the Daniel Ceron has a novel
idea at least 10,000 Raheen gia were
killed in Myanmar in 2017 more than
700,000 have escaped to Bangladesh and
during the Myanmar military's campaign
of massacre and rape women's bodies
became a terrain of conflict
my dad was a boy at the end using I did
a photo - I didn't it illegal to
invisible Shafiq ax is not alone
although there are no specific figures
of how many pregnancies have occurred
because of these rapes at least two
thousand seven hundred survivors of
sexual and gender-based violence have
received help in the camps
leigh-anne Malakian my you didn't let me
Shafiq I made it to Gundam refugee camp
after treacherous five-day journey here
she was reunited with her husband 20
days later not abhi she might roses even
today that's a good idea
then I ain't on the ladder wondaland
allahu if by some are getting really
[Music]
Anila follow that she doesn't want to
mother india
me she do lago de talking good doing
solid resume an anomaly take me judge
and 11 visit the canal
well then 60 Ranger babies are born in
the refugee camps in bangladesh every
day the conditions for pregnant women in
the camps are dire
especially for survivors of sexual
violence it was a detour in de la my
little ache yata mother neither
artificial but the other with them
Shafiq has denied citizenship in myanmar
to raise her baby in this camp when it's
born
despite the perilous conditions
she and her newborn child will have to
face in the world's largest refugee camp
chef iike will not go back to myanmar
[Music]
haunted you know the Buddha man American
attacking neighbor Medea nomads I will
accept an Alabama rule Ana to dilemma
Ganga neighbors and Larry Garber Macondo
Florida Berlin
vanilla garden in Eden Eliyahu GB team
are gonna let the cemetery had even
anyway so what the her Angela Baba
cooling pool my generous over about them
you